guten Morgen und Willkommen zu heute
live ja ungewöhnlich früh sind wir heute
für euch auf Sendung aber es ist ja auch
kein gewöhnlicher nachrichtentag es geht
um die Demokratie als solche so sagt es
zumindest der US-amerikanische Präsident
Joe Biden und seinen Vorgänger Donald
Trump meint es sei an der Zeit die
Zerstörung der USA zu stoppen also mehr
Polarisierung mehr Spaltung geht kaum es
sind Zwischenwahlen in den USA und um
die wollen wir uns heute kümmern wir
sprechen gleich mit meiner Kollegin
Alexandra havlin die uns aus Arizona
einem sehr umkämpften Staat zugeschaltet
sein wird wir sprechen mit der
Politikwissenschaftlerin Katherine
clüvereschbruch über die möglichen
Folgen der Wahl auch für uns hier in
Europa und in Deutschland und wir
beginnen gleich mit MRT wir sind dem
Leiter unseres Studios in Washington
aber vorher bringt uns meine Kollegin
Heikes lanski auf den aktuellen Stand
wie die Wahl bislang abgelaufen ist
der Wahlkrimi im amerikanischen
Fernsehen
ein Kopf an kopfrennen zwischen
Republikanern und Demokraten noch ist
nicht klar wer die Mehrheit im
neugewählten Kongress stellen wird den
ganzen Tag erreichten uns diese Bilder
Schlange stehen für die Stimmabgabe laut
FBI ohne nennenswerte Zwischenfälle mal
funktionierte zwar eine wahlmaschine
nicht es musste manuell ausgezählt
werden mal müsste sich ein trump-fan
unter die Wahlhelfer und wurde entfernt
Amerika hat gewählt die Wahlbeteiligung
so hoch wie noch nie Beweggründe
die Inflation die Wirtschaft die Preise
sind horrent hoch ich dachte ich könnte
dieses Jahr in den Ruhestand gehen jetzt
muss ich noch ein Jahr warten es ist
schlimm
es geht um Abtreibung um die Umwelt um
sicherzustellen dass jeder die
Möglichkeit hat zu wählen
die Wirtschaft funktioniert nur für die
Reichen es ist ein abgekartetes Spiel
wenn wir das nicht ändern werden wir
untergehen
zur Wahl standen nicht nur alle
Kongressabgeordnete und ein Drittel der
Senatoren sondern auch Gouverneure innen
und Justizminister der Bundesstaaten
darunter hunderte die behaupten Joe
Biden sei nicht rechtmäßig gewählt
worden obwohl das von Gerichten zigfach
widerlegt wurde
es ist mir als Amerikaner gelinde gesagt
sehr unangenehm zu sehen was da passiert
natürlich kann jeder sagen was er will
aber unser System funktioniert seit
Jahrhunderten so dass man Beweise
vorliegen muss dass es eine Justiz gibt
die über diese Behauptungen entscheidet
auch wenn er gar nicht zur Wahl stand
zog Trump bei den Republikanern im
Hintergrund die Fäden viele Kandidaten
die er unterstützt kopieren seinen rauen
Stil
gerade da hinten wollen nicht dass wir
über gestohlene Wahlen sprechen
wir können und wir werden Joe Biden
anklagen
zur Stunde wird noch ausgezählt eine
Zitterpartie für die Demokraten die ihre
hauchdünne Mehrheit im Kongress
verlieren könnten
und ich begrüße Elma tevenson in
Washington und zugeschaltet aus dem
Studio dort guten Morgen und das kann
man in deinem Fall wirklich richtig
wörtlich nehmen bei euch ist es halb
zwei in der Früh
guten Morgen Christopher hallo ja Elmar
wir gucken gleich auf die ersten Trends
bzw zahlen aber vielleicht noch mal ganz
kurz vorweg eine Information glaube ich
kann man schon geben und sagen die
Wahlen sind enger als es im Vorfeld
erwartet worden war
ja das ist so man hatte ja hier von
einer roten Welle geredet das heißt dass
ein sehr sehr deutlicher Sieg im
Abgeordnetenhaus für die Republikaner
anstehen würde und das sie es auch
schaffen würden den Senat für sich zu
entscheiden also die Mehrheit am Ende zu
haben bisher ist sie ja fifty-fifty und
die Vizepräsidentin war dann immer die
entscheidende Stimme in den letzten zwei
Jahren diese rote Welle ist ausgeblieben
bisher jedenfalls weil man gesehen hat
dass einige Rennen in denen es sehr sehr
knapp war und bei denen die Republikaner
damit gerechnet hatten dass sie ihre
Kandidaten durchbringen für das
Repräsentantenhaus nicht funktioniert
haben auch nicht im Senat aber es ist
noch früh wir warten immer noch auf eine
Menge Ergebnisse das einzige was man
sagen kann ist dass die Republikaner
nicht schaffen werden was normalerweise
der Durchschnitt ist bei der Anzahl der
Sitze die man im Repräsentantenhaus
gewinnt in einer zwischenwahl in einer
ersten Amtszeit eines Präsidenten dieser
Durchschnitt ist nämlich eigentlich 30
mand die dann von der jeweiligen
nichtregierungs- oder nicht
Präsidentenpartei gewonnen werden das
ist der Schnitt aus den letzten ja
Jahrzehnten im Grunde genommen da werden
die Republikaner deutlich drunter
bleiben sie könnten dennoch sowohl das
Repräsentantenhaus am Ende gewinnen als
auch eben den Senat für sich entscheiden
wobei letzteres unwahrscheinlicher ist
als der Sieg eben immer präsentantenhaus
ja davon war ja auch im Vorfeld
ausgegangen worden dass es da eben zu
einem Wechsel wohl kommen würde wir
schauen vielleicht gerade mal bei uns
auf unserer Seite ZDF heute.de und
schauen uns an dass da eben auch immer
ganz aktuell natürlich geguckt wird okay
wie sind die neuesten Zahlen aus den USA
da haben wir zum Beispiel hier das
Demokrat fetter man in Pennsylvania
gewinnt eben auch einer der swingstase
da können wir nachher auch noch mal
drauf eingehen was das dann für eine
Bedeutung hat wir sehen hier unten
weiter dass eben es wie immer auch
gerade angesprochen hat relativ enges
hier ist also noch mal Zahlen zum
Repräsentantenhaus momentan der Stand
567 aber 76 eben auch noch nicht
ausgezählt man kann sich hier gerne mal
durchklicken also ganz informativ
wirklich sehr empfehlenswert das mal zu
Hause auch nachzuvollziehen wie der
Stand im Moment in den einzelnen Staaten
auch so ist das ist hier wie gesagt sind
Zahlen zum Repräsentanten Haus aber hier
sind auch Zahlen zum Senat und da haben
wir eben auch im Moment also das ist ja
die Situation die wir hatten seit 2020
ein Part 5050 auch das hat immer gerade
angesprochen und auch da sieht es eben
relativ knapp aus im Moment 47 zu 47 und
das versuchen wir ihm auch weiter zu
aktualisieren und wir versuchen das
natürlich auch in den Livestream dann
immer mal wieder mit einzubeziehen Elmer
wir haben das gerade auch im Beitrag
schon gehört was sind denn die Themen
die die Menschen in den USA derzeit
besonders umtreiben es ist ja eine
relativ hohe Wahlbeteiligung auch das
hat Heikes ganzki angesprochen was ist
es was die Leute momentan da doch zu
ohne treibt
ja wir wissen sowohl aus Umfragen vorher
als auch jetzt von den sogenannten
exit-polster sind die Befragungen wenn
die Menschen aus den Wahllokalen
herauskommen dass das allerwichtigste
Thema die Wirtschaft die Inflation ist
die Preissteigerungen
über 70 Prozent der Amerikaner sind
höchst und höchst unzufrieden mit der
Entwicklung der US-Wirtschaft 75%
genauer gesagt nach diesen sogenannten
exit-pols und das bedeutet dass viele
von ihnen auch ein Stück weit dem dem
derzeitigen Präsidenten Joe Biden und
den Demokraten eine Schuld dafür geben
obwohl man über diese Frage trefflich
streiten könnte also das ist das
Wichtigste treibende Thema bei dieser
Wahl gewesen aber nicht weiter hinter
und das hat viele Beobachter überrascht
liegt offenbar das Thema Abtreibung auf
das hatten die Demokraten ja gesetzt
nachdem eben das Oberste Gericht im Juni
das amerikanische Abtreibungsrecht das
recht liberal ist gekippt hatte und
dieses Recht in die Bundesstaaten
zurückgegeben hatte das hat mobilisiert
das hat motiviert offenbar tatsächlich
so wie die Demokraten sich das gehofft
hatten das nämlich tatsächlich in
einigen Bundesstaaten mit diesem Thema
ganz konkret auch Abgeordnete Senatoren
aber auch
Ämter in den einzelnen Bundesstaaten
Gouverneure oder eben auch innen und
Justizminister auf dieser Basis die Wahl
gewonnen haben aber nochmal es ist früh
wir sehen natürlich an einigen Stellen
auch dass sich Kandidaten der
Republikaner durchgesetzt haben die
einerseits auf dem Thema Wirtschaft vor
allen Dingen ihren Wahlkampf aufgebaut
haben andererseits aber auch einige
Kandidaten dabei sind die ich sag mal
trampisten sind also von Donald Trump
unterstützt werden das sind ein bisschen
gemischt das Ergebnis einige haben es
geschafft einige nicht aber einige vor
allen Dingen die der wahllüge anhängen
insgesamt
157 von insgesamt etwa 300 Kandidaten
die im Wahlkampf auch offen diese
wahllüge von angeblich gestohlenen
Präsidentschaftswahl 2020 verbreitet
haben
157 von diesen knapp 300 sind
tatsächlich die Sieger in ihren
jeweiligen Rennen gewesen das heißt es
bedeutet dass wir im Kongress hier aber
auch in einigen Bundesstaaten eine Reihe
von Abgeordneten Senatoren oder auch in
anderen Ämtern haben werden die eben
tatsächlich dieser wahllüge anhängen mal
danke bis hierhin wir werden das gleich
noch mal aufgreifen auf die Aspekte die
du gerade angesprochen hast vielleicht
auch noch mal der Hinweis an euch
draußen natürlich wie immer gerne
mitmachen Fragen stellen Kommentare
schreiben an uns über E-Mail oder über
unsere Social Media Kanäle aber wir
wollen uns noch mit ein paar Fakten zur
aktuellen Situation versorgen Sarah
lasar hat das gemacht
im Repräsentantenhaus werden alle
Abgeordneten neu gewählt 435 Sitze
insgesamt 218 sind für eine Mehrheit
nötig stand 7 Uhr kommen die Demokraten
auf 167 Sitze die Republikaner auf 1000
im Senat werden 35 der 100 Mandate neu
vergeben die Demokraten kommen aktuell
auf 10 der 35 Sitze die Republikaner auf
17 insgesamt steht es hier also 46 zu 46
also das noch mal ein Überblick über die
beiden Kammern wie gesagt ich habe es
gerade schon gezeigt auf unserer
Homepage unter anderem finden sich da
immer aktuelle und neue Zahlen das lohnt
sich das wird laufend aktualisiert das
mal nachzuvollziehen immer wir haben
gerade die beiden kann man noch mal
vorgestellt bekommen und das ist
vielleicht ja auch für unsere Zuschauer
noch mal wichtig was bedeutet es denn
jetzt wenn die Demokraten die momentan
in beiden Kongress kann man eine knappe
Mehrheit haben jetzt in der einen oder
in der anderen oder in beiden kann man
die Mehrheit verlieren welche
Auswirkungen hätte das für die Arbeit
des US-Präsidenten
ja gehen wir mal mit dem
Repräsentantenhaus an den Start also
wenn die Republikaner doch die Mehrheit
haben und auch wenn es eine knappe
Mehrheit sein sollte oder knappere als
erwartet worden ist dann werden Sie
diese Macht nutzen um eben die
wichtigsten Vorhaben des Präsidenten für
die zweite Hälfte seiner ersten Amtszeit
zu torpedieren zu stoppen die
Republikaner haben auch schon
signalisiert dass wenn sie dann eben den
Sprecher des Abgeordnetenhauses stellen
also Nachfolge für Nancy Pelosi das
könnte Kevin McCarthy sein derzeitiger
minderheitenführer der Republikaner dass
man dann auch
Untersuchungsausschüsse einsetzen will
gegen die Regierung unter anderem den
Afghanistan Abzug noch mal genauer
untersuchen will hat die Vorwürfe gegen
Hunter beiden den Sohn des Präsidenten
aber auch in vielen anderen Punkten
Untersuchungsausschüsse einsetzen will
und das wird natürlich das Weiße Haus
den Präsidenten unter Druck setzen das
heißt die innenpolitische Agenda und
wirtschaftspolitische Agenda könnte auf
diese Weise zu einem guten Teil gestoppt
werden das zweite ist der Senat der ist
ja unter anderem auch sehr wichtig für
die amerikanische Außenpolitik wenn die
Demokraten doch die Mehrheit verlieren
sollten im Senat also in beiden Häusern
da die Mehrheit verloren haben dann
schränkt das die Macht des Präsidenten
massiv ein weil Senat und
Repräsentantenhaus gemeinsam ja
entscheiden auch über das Geld das zur
Verfügung steht für
außenpolitische Aktivitäten
beispielsweise für die Ukraine Hilfe und
auch da haben die Republikaner schon
signalisiert sie wollten die Milliarden
die bisher an die Ukraine geflossen sind
oder vielleicht noch fließen sollen auf
den Prüfstand stellen das wird
schwieriger für den Präsidenten erkannt
trotzdem mit seiner exekutiv macht
einiges bewegen und einiges entscheiden
wenn es eben nicht um riesige Geldsummen
geht und im Senat gilt natürlich auch
dass die Minderheit durch den
sogenannten Filibuster in der Lage ist
Vorhaben der Mehrheit auch ein Stück
weit zu bremsen und zu stoppen und
auszusetzen also der Präsident Joe
beiden müsste sehr mit seiner exekutiv
Vollmacht dann regieren kommt es zu
einem gemischten Ergebnis also das
Repräsentantenhaus geht an die
Republikaner über wie gesagt das ist
sehr wahrscheinlich und im Senat kann
der Präsident auf eine Mehrheit
weiterhin zurückgreifen vielleicht sogar
es nicht ausgeschlossen eine Mehrheit
die etwas deutlicher ist als es in den
in den letzten zwei Jahren der Fall war
dann könnte er seine wichtigsten
außenpolitischen Vorhaben durchbringen
er hat auch eine Chance weitere
Kandidaten für Gerichte in den USA
Bundesgerichte auch den Obersten
Gerichtshof durchzubringen also er wäre
eben keine lahme Ente sondern könnte
dennoch einiges für das Land bewegen
interessant wird eben wie polarisiert in
der Politik in den nächsten zwei Jahren
dann die Auseinandersetzung wird und das
könnte dann eben ein bisschen auch die
Bühne bauen für die Präsidentschaftswahl
2024 denn
massiver Vorgehen im präsentantenhaus
mit Untersuchungsausschüssen wird
natürlich auch die Emotionen
entsprechend hochtreiben im Land wir
haben es gerade schon angesprochen in
Pennsylvania einem der umstrittenen
Staaten und da werden wir oder
beziehungsweise stark umkämpften starten
und da werden wir gleich auch noch mal
drauf schauen gab es eben auch ein
Ergebnis das sieht jetzt eben alles sehr
danach aus dass dort sich der Demokrat
durchgesetzt hat fetter man vor seinem
republikanischen Gegner auch dazu glaube
ich gibt es ein Bild wenn ich es richtig
weiß wenn wir das haben können wir das
uns gerne noch mal anschauen wenn nicht
machen wir das später
ja da haben wir ihn Christopher
vielleicht das ist ein wichtiges Signal
im Pennsylvania auch also es sieht
danach aus als würde John fetter man
eben den Senatssitz gewinnen für den
Bundesstaat Pennsylvania den Senats
jetzt im Senat hier in Washington wenn
das geschieht dann wäre das eben eine
klare Absage an den Kandidaten der dort
angetreten ist Mech mit Oz ein Arzt der
sich voll auf die Trump Linie begeben
hat der hier eine Niederlage erleidet
und das wäre ein ganz wichtiger
senatsitz gewesen für die Republikaner
um wirklich am Ende auch hier die
Mehrheit zu bekommen und in Pennsylvania
hat eben auch der republikanische
Kandidat der eindeutig auf trumplinie
ist der in Teilen sich auch rassistisch
antisemitisch geäußert hat und der vor
allen Dingen auch die Lüge von der
angeblich gestohlenen
Präsidentschaftswahl verbreitet hat
dagmastriano dieser Kandidat hat die
Wahl zum Gouverneur verloren und das
auch einigermaßen deutlich also sieht es
gibt auch eine Absage der Wähler an
extreme Kandidaten der Gewinner ist eben
ein Demokrat George Shapiro der auch zur
jüngeren Generation gehört und ich
glaube dass auch ein Signal dass wir an
verschiedenen Stellen hier bei dieser
Wahl sehen dass tatsächlich auch jüngere
Kandidaten eine Chance hatten sich
durchzusetzen ja ganz interessante
Hintergrundinformationen auch noch mal
dafür vielen Dank wir nehmen mal die ein
oder andere User Frage mit auf Elmar
Youtube bzw will dich fragen flauschiger
Keks ist der Name dauert es wieder so
lange bis das Endergebnis feststeht oder
geht es schneller als bei der
Präsidentschaftswahl
ich glaube es kann lange dauern wir
sehen in einigen Bundesstaaten dass es
schwerer geworden ist auszuzählen
beispielsweise hat man sich entschieden
weil es irgendwo Probleme gab mit
Wahlmaschinen bzw auszählmaschine dass
man eben noch mal genauer auszählt per
Hand zusätzlich für schon die ersten
Ergebnisse beispielsweise in Arizona es
kann etwas länger dauern in Pennsylvania
ist das auch der Fall da hat man sich
entschieden um sicher zu gehen dass eben
hinterher diese Wahl nicht angefochten
werden kann will man im
Überprüfungsprozess welche Stimmen
gültig oder ungültig sind noch ein
zusatzschritt mit einführen das hat man
auch gemacht auch deshalb kann es doch
länger dauern das gleiche gilt für
Georgia und einige andere Bundesstaaten
lange Rede kurzer Sinn ja es ist so es
kann noch eine Weile dauern wir wir
sehen zwar den Trend dass die
Republikaner eben das Repräsentantenhaus
gewinnen werden aber beim Senat
beispielsweise kann es noch eine Weile
dauern in Georg ist das Rennen um den
Senatsposten den derzeit Ralph Warner
inne hat ein Demokrat der vor der vor
zwei Jahren eben eher überraschend
diesen Senatssitz gewonnen hat der muss
diesen verteidigen gegen hercial Walker
in Kandidat der umstritten ist der
unterstützt wird von dolmet Donald Trump
das Ergebnis ist knapp aber weil da ein
dritter Kandidat im Rennen ist kann es
eben sein dass wir noch mal eine
Stichwahl haben werden die dann erst im
Dezember stattfindet also wenn es
insgesamt beim Senat knapp wird kann es
durchaus sein dass wir das Endergebnis
also wer die Mehrheit im Senat hier in
Washington hat erst im Dezember
irgendwann erfahren werden also da ist
dann offenbar Geduld gefragt jaydog
fragt uns über Youtube viele
Republikaner haben ja angedeutet ihre
Abwahl nicht weil nicht anerkennen zu
wollen das ist ja sozusagen auch noch
mal die Frage nach den demokratischen
Spielregeln inwieweit akzeptieren die
Republikaner diese eigentlich überhaupt
noch man kann da Annahmen denken wie
auch Gary lake zum Beispiel über die wir
gleich auch mit Alexandra Haflinger
sprechen werden in Arizona also wie
schätzt du das ein werden die ihre
Niederlage anerkennen
das ist eben schwer zu sagen weil einige
Kandidaten sich gewissermaßen schon warm
gelaufen haben oder Vorbereitungen
getroffen haben um hinterher zu klagen
ich will mal ein Beispiel nennen
Christina caramo Republikanerin die eben
in Michigan angetreten ist um das Amt
der Innenministerin sich beworben hat
caramo ebenfalls eine die der wahllüge
anhängt die sogar extreme Überzeugungen
vertritt hat sie uns in die Kamera
gesagt dass Amerika keine Demokratie sei
weil in einer Demokratie ja die Mehrheit
von der minder die Minderheit von der
Mehrheit zu Tode geknüppelt werden kann
die Minderheit keinen Schutz genießt das
ist nach amerikanischem Rechtssystem
natürlich Blödsinn aber diese Kandidatin
hat nach den Ergebnissen jetzt wohl sehr
deutlich verloren und hat vor dieser
Wahl schon eine Klage eingereicht gegen
die Briefwahlstimmen in einem Bezirk
rund um die Detroit herum um auf diese
Weise auch gerichtlich schon ich sag
jetzt mal einen kleinen Sprengsatz die
Lunte gelegt zu haben haben um hinterher
eben das Gesamtergebnis nicht
anzuerkennen wir wissen noch nicht ob
sie das Ergebnis akzeptiert und das
werden wir auch dann bei Cary Lake sehen
müssen da geht es um das Gouverneursamt
in Arizona die republikanische
Kandidatin Carey Lake wird als
weiblicher Trump gesehen und wird im
Grunde genommen auch angesehen als
mögliche
Präsidentschaftskandidatin der
republikanischen Partei für 2024 und die
hat eben vorher auch schon signalisiert
dass sie vielleicht ein Ergebnis in dem
sie verliert nicht alle erkennen würde
na da haben sie auch gerade im Bild
ehemalige TV-Moderatorin eben auch mit
schon starke rechts populistischen bis
extremen Äußerungen eben aufgefallen im
Wahlkampf da werden wir sehen was wir
dazu erwarten haben wie gesagt das
gleich auch noch mal Thema im Gespräch
mit Alexandra havlin aus Arizona wir
wollten noch kurz sprechen höre ich
gerade über meinen Kopfhörer über
Florida mit dir Elmar da sieht es
momentan so aus dass auch dieser Staat
wohl in republikanischer Hand ist auch
da glaube ich für uns Bilder anschauen
ich gucke gerade mal hoch ob da jetzt
schon was kommt jedenfalls ist es so
dass wir hatten vorhin schon gesprochen
auch über das Gouverneurs Gouverneurs
Amt dort über run the Säntis der wäre ja
auch eventuell jemand der Ambition nicht
nur eventuell er hat es mehr oder
weniger schon unverhohlen auch gesagt
Ambitionen hat auf das Amt des
US-Präsidenten haben wir noch gerade im
Bild
inwieweit ist er sich mit Trump da einig
ich wenn ich das jetzt richtig beobachte
aus der Ferne kann man das durchaus
bezweifeln bzw Trump nimmt ihn glaube
ich schon auch als sehr ernst zu
nehmenden Widersacher war und da gibt es
sogar so eine Art Scharmützel zwischen
den beiden vielleicht kannst du uns
diese Situation noch mal ein bisschen
erläutern
ja das kann man klar sagen dass die
beiden sich nicht grün sind so würde man
es wohl ausdrücken rundesantes hat im
Wahlkampf sehr Klarsicht distanziert von
Donald Trump hat sich auch entfernt
gehalten von ihm und Donald Trump weiß
sehr genau dass das wahrscheinlich sein
gefährlichster Gegenkandidat innerhalb
der eigenen Partei wäre wenn Trump denn
tatsächlich antreten würde und ronde
Santes hat einen Erdrutschsieg
eingefahren so deutlich die
gouverneurs-wahl gewonnen unter anderem
auch mit den Stimmen der Latinos zum
ersten Mal seit Jeb Bush das tatsächlich
der Kandidat der republikanischen Partei
so deutlich eben auch die Stimmen der
Latinos bekommen hat und das gibt ihm
natürlich Rückenwind wir sind eigentlich
sicher dass rondes Antis seine
Kandidatur für die Präsidentschaft über
kurz oder lang in den nächsten Monaten
irgendwann ankündigen wird egal ob Trump
antritt oder nicht und für uns ist auch
interessant zu sehen dass in Florida
eben doch einiges an neuen Dingen
geschehen ist trotz dieser eindeutigen
Stimmabgabe für ronde Santis sehen wir
auch das neue Dinge passieren zum
Beispiel der jüngste Kandidat je ein
25-jähriger der in das
Repräsentantenhaus nach Washington
entsandt wird durch Florida also zum
ersten mal jemand von der Generation See
Generation Z wie man hier sagt geht nach
Washington und auch an anderen Stellen
sehen wir einige ich sag mal historische
Momente das beispielsweise zwei Frauen
tatsächlich erstmals für Bundesstaaten
Gouverneure werden in arkensaar und in
Massachusetts in Massachusetts eine
Demokratin die lesbisch ist auch das ist
ein ein erstes Mal insgesamt in den USA
sogar dass eine lesbische Kandidatin
Gouverneurin eines Bundesstaates wird
und wir sehen auch an anderen Stellen
zum Beispiel den Maryland den ersten
schwarzen Gouverneur für den Bundesstaat
Maryland für die Demokraten auch das ein
sehr deutliches Signal dass eine junge
andere Generation eben in die Ämter
kommt auch wesmore ist noch
vergleichsweise jung also es bahnt sich
ein Stück weit ein Generationswechsel ab
der na ich sag mal auch ein Stück weit
auf die Zukunft Amerikas hindeutet
ändert nichts daran der nächste
Wahlkampf wird sicherlich ausgefochten
werden gegen zwischenpersonen wie
beispielsweise Donald Trump und run
daysantes und wir rechnen ja alle damit
dass Donald Trump nächste Woche Dienstag
so hat er es angekündigt eine große
Neuigkeit verkündet wenn er das auf der
Basis der Ergebnisse tut dann könnte es
sogar sein dass er vielleicht nicht
antritt denn eben nicht alle sondern
deutlich weniger als erwartet seiner
Kandidaten haben sich durchgesetzt also
der Trappisten in den Bundesstaaten oder
auch für den Kongress in Washington und
run de Santis sein wohl gefährlichster
widersache hat eben massiven Rückenwind
bekommen durch diesen Erdrutschsieg also
die erhoffte redwave die rote Welle für
Donald Trump ist ausgeblieben könnte
dazu führen dass er vielleicht sogar
nicht antritt das werden wir dann
nächste Woche erfahren dass immer
teweson pardon das war wie immer
ausgesprochen informativ und
kenntnisreich unser ZDF Studioleiter in
Washington ganz herzlichen Dank für
diese Analysen und Einordnungen und wir
sprechen mit Alexandra Havel jetzt
direkt weiter in Arizona bleiben also in
den USA zugeschaltet und sie ist für uns
dort auf der Wahlparty der Republikaner
und da wäre natürlich jetzt meine erste
Frage der Staat ist glaube ich offiziell
noch nicht ganz ausgezählt was sind
deine Informationen wie ist momentan der
Stand der Dinge bei euch
wie ein Arizona dauert es bekanntlich
sehr lange bis die endgültigen
Ergebnisse feststellen ein Beispiel erst
am nächsten Tag am darauffolgenden Tag
werden die Briefwahlstimmen ausgezählt
das ist auch meistens der Grund der
Leute ein bisschen misstrauisch werden
lässt dass das Ergebnis eben nicht in
der Wahlnacht schon vorliegt nach dem
jetzigen Stand sind 50 Prozent der
Stimmen ausgezählt und die
republikanischen Kandidaten haben ein
paar Verluste eingebüßt wenn man es mit
den Prognosen vergleicht die carry Lake
die gouverneurskandidatin hat nach
jetzigem Stand ungefähr 44 Prozent liegt
also hinter ihrer demokratischen
Konkurrentin Katie hops und auch Blake
Masters der senatskandidat liegt hinter
dem demokratenmarkt Kelly
interessante Informationen zum
Zwischenstand es gibt in ariz Experten
sind schon angesprochen offenbar
Probleme mit den wahlautomaten ein
Umstand der ja auch eher den
Republikanern in die Hände spielen
dürfte weil das natürlich wieder so die
Legende befeuert von gefälschten oder
manipulierten Wahlen was ist dazu zu
sagen
[Applaus]
ja genau es wurde heute bekannt dass
ungefähr jeder fünfte wahlautomaten
nicht funktioniert hat wenige Stunden
später haben dann die Verantwortlichen
die für die Wahl den das Problem
herausgefunden und haben gesagt das lag
an den Druckereinstellungen die Tinte
war die stark genug und die Automaten
konnten die Stimmzettel nicht lesen das
heißt aber nicht dass die Stimmzettel
nicht ausgezählt wurden jeder einzelne
Stimmzettel wird hier gezählt das hat
der für die Wahl verantwortliche
Recorder Steven Richard heute auch noch
mal betont aber natürlich für die
republikanischen Kandidaten die hier für
die wichtigsten Ämter antreten und die
Lüge von der gestohlenen Wahl
propagieren ist das natürlich heute
gefundenes Fressen
wie hast Du um das jetzt noch mal
vielleicht auch auf dem Wahlkampf zu
beziehen die letzten Tage und Wochen
dort in Arizona erlebt ich nehme an der
Wahlkampf dort ist mit einem Wahlkampf
in Deutschland gerade unter den
gegenwärtigen Voraussetzungen
Stichwort aus Keepers die sich glaube
ich dazu auch eben bereit gefunden haben
oder es zumindest vorhatten die Wahl
dort zu bewachen wie Sie es nennen ist
nicht zu vergleichen mit einem deutschen
Wahlkampf viel wir sind deine Eindrücke
gewesen in den letzten Tagen
[Musik]
ja die Stimmung war sehr angespannt
ja ich höre ich noch weiter das lenkt
mich gerade ab okay
[Musik]
ich versuche es noch mal gerade kannst
du uns noch hören Alexandra die Frage
war wie hast du den Wahlkampf der
letzten Tage erlebt
ja Christopher jetzt für richtig
die Lage war sehr angespannt man hat
sich auf diesen Endspurt im Wahlkampf so
vorbereitet wie nie zuvor die Kandidaten
also gerade die Republikaner waren noch
mal sehr aktiv mit einer Bus zu ab also
alle wichtigen Kandidaten sind die
letzten drei Tage mit dem Bus durchs
Land geturt und die Behörden und die
Wahlhelfer aber waren sehr angespannt
denn man muss dazu sagen Arizona ist ein
Bundesstaat in dem Donald Trump immer
noch nicht seine Niederlage 2020
eingestanden hat und das hat zu einer
Atmosphäre geführt die zu
Morddrohungen gegen Wahlhelfer führt und
versuchen der wahleinschüchterung also
der Einschüchterung von WLAN deshalb hat
man sich hier sehr breit aufgestellt der
Sheriff hat gestern gesagt
sich noch nie so gerüstet er hat in 30
Jahren wo im Amt ist noch nie so etwas
erlebt und nie daran geglaubt dass er
irgendwann Zäune vor den wahlstationen
aufbauen muss es waren sehr viele
Streifen des Sheriffs unterwegs
Mitarbeiter des Sherrys auch in Zivil
sie sind von Wahlstation zu Wahlstation
gefahren und haben die Situation
kontrolliert im Blick gehabt ich durfte
mit einer Streife heute mitfahren und
die gute Nachricht ist dass es in dem
County wo ich war keine Zwischenfälle
gegeben hat das ist beruhigend und wir
hoffen dass es auch so bleibt wir haben
vorhin carry Lake gesehen wir müssen
noch mal kurz auf sie zu sprechen kommen
auch wenn sie jetzt dort vielleicht
nicht gewinnt aber sie ist im Vorfeld
eine prominente Figur gewesen in diesem
Wahlkampf weil sie auch als neue
Hoffnungsträgerin der Republikaner gilt
matthesen hatte sie vorhin auch schon
kurz angesprochen was kannst du uns über
diese Frau noch erzählen
ist das neue Phänomen unter den
Republikanern sie ist wie du sagst ein
Shooting Star sie war über 20 Jahre lang
TV-Moderatorin hier in Phoenix bei Fox
und hat dann 2021 sehr spontan und
überraschend entschieden sich dem
Medienbusiness komplett den Rücken
zuzukehren und bezeichnet die Presse
jetzt nur noch als mainstream media und
Fake News sie hat in ihrem Wahlkampf vor
allem mit der Lüge von der gestohlenen
Wahl gepunktet sie bezeichnet Donald
Trump als ihren Freund und wie es Elmar
schon vorhin angesprochen hat sie wird
immer wieder gefragt ob sie denn als
Präsidentschaftskandidatin 2024 antreten
will oder als Vizepräsidentin mit Donald
Trump darauf hat sie gegenüber den
Medien gesagt sie wird es nicht machen
sie will Gouverneurin werden und sie
wird dann der Albtraum der schlimmste
Albtraum für die Medien für acht Jahre
lang werden
wenn Sie gewinnen würde noch sind nicht
alle Stimmen ausgezählt noch liegt sie
zurück aber wenn Sie gewinnen würde
würde das sehr viel aussagen wie die
Menschen hier in Arizona über die Wahl
2020 denken und wie groß Trumps Einfluss
noch immer ist auch das noch mal
bedenkliche Einschätzungen zumindest was
auch die Rolle der Medien angeht in den
USA vielen Dank Alexandra habe den war
das für uns aus Arizona Dankeschön für
diese Eindrücke und das war sehr laut
aber wir konnten dich gut verstehen
denke ich danke schön
so und wir sprechen gleich ich habe es
vorhin schon angekündigt mit Katherine
Klüver asbook einer Politik
Wissenschaftlerin auch Beraterin die uns
gleich zugeschaltet sein wird aus Berlin
wollen aber die kurze Pause vielleicht
gerade noch mal nutzen um auf die
aktuellen Zahlen zu schauen wie wir sie
auch hier auf unserer Seite bei ZDF
heute.de finden und wir sehen das im
momentan im Senat die Verteilung 48 zu
47 zu Gunsten der Demokraten ist der
aktuelle Stand davor war 50 zu 50 5
Sitze sind also noch zu vergeben es
bleibt nach wie vor ein äußerst
spannendes Rennen über das ich jetzt
spreche ich habe es gesagt mit Katherine
Klüver asbrook die uns hoffentlich hört
aus Berlin da ist sie guten Morgen Frau
küverestock guten Morgen aus Berlin mit
alternativen haben wir vorhin schon
gesprochen darüber welche Bedeutung
diese Wahl hat und die Demokraten die
Spanier nicht mit partus die
Republikaner allerdings auch nicht also
die Demokratie als solche sozusagen
stünde auf dem Spiel
wie sehen Sie das ja das ist ganz
richtig 70 Prozent der Amerikaner machen
sich selber Sorgen um den Zustand ihre
eigenen Demokratie da ist natürlich dann
aber noch mal die einzelne Perspektive
wichtig die Republikaner glauben
weiterhin mehrheitlich auch wenn sich da
die Zahl etwas verringert hat hin zu
diesen mütterns das Donald Trump die
Wahl 2020 gestohlen worden ist und MRT
Wissen hat schon angesprochen dass diese
amerikanischen Wahlzettel sind ja lange
weit über 150 Kandidaten sich über das
ganze Land für verschiedene Ämter zur
Wahl gestellt haben deren Hauptpunkt
genau dieser ist es gelbe massiven
Eingriff in das amerikanische Wahlsystem
Donald Trump sei die Wahl gestohlen
worden man könne der demokratischen Wahl
an sich nicht mehr Vertrauen und das
untergräbt ja weiterhin das Verständnis
der Amerikaner ihrer eigenen Demokratie
und dem Fortbestehen ihre eigenen
Demokratie also ist das für Demokraten
auch im Vorlauf neben der
Abtreibungsfrage einen ganz eine ganz
große Motivation gewesen heute an die
Wahlurne zu gehen oder ihre
briefwahlzettel abzugeben und wie wir
sehen eben besonders auch für junge
Amerikaner eliminatives und hat die
Generation Z schon angesprochen das war
die die Gruppe die die
umfrageunternehmen nicht wirklich an die
umfrageunternehmen nicht wirklich ran
kam und es könnte gut sein dass jetzt
diese rote Welle zum Teil abgehalten
worden ist von jungen Amerikanern die
nehme ich diesen demokratieverfall die
davor große Angst haben und sich dadurch
hoch motiviert gefühlt haben Chris the
darkers fragt uns über Youtube was
bringt denn ein demokratischer oder
republikanischer Präsident wenn der
Senat oder das Repräsentantenhaus dann
immer das Gegenteil ist es führt ja in
einen ewigen Kreislauf in dem nichts
vorangeht naja gut also so ist ganz
amerikanische politische System
gestrickt das nämlich durch die
Gewaltenteilung das ist in vielen
Demokratien so angelegt dass die
unterschiedlichen kann man sich eben
jeweils kontrollieren in einem zwei
Parteiensystem ist es dann natürlich
wirklich so wie der Fragende beschreibt
es ist kann sein dass da natürlich
eine Situation rauskommt wie wir über
die letzten Jahrzehnte in der
amerikanischen Politik gesehen haben
nämlich eine komplette Blockadepolitik
natürlich ist das System so angelegt von
den konstitutionellen von den
verfassungsvätern wenn man so möchte es
waren alles Männer das sich die beiden
Parteien dann einigen sollen das ist der
demokratische Prozess die Verhandlung
zwischen den beiden Parteien aber in der
Reihe Realität haben wir natürlich
gesehen dass im Grunde genommen seit der
Amtszeit von Bill Clinton nach vorne
gedacht und besonders auch in den
obama-jahren dann am Ende der
obama-jahre die Republikaner ganz klar
nur auf Blockade geschaltet haben und
das wird natürlich jetzt auch je nach
Ausgang es wird denkbar knapp in beiden
Kammern Joe B nach vorne sowohl innen
wie auch in der außenpolitisch
einschränken wird wir sprechen gleich
noch über die auch außenpolitischen
folgen die diese Wahl haben könnte
gerade noch mal die Frage von politiko 1
N1 wie schätzen sie denn die Folgen der
Wahl von republikanischen state
secretary Kandidaten ein auf die Wahlen
in 2024 da muss man jetzt zur Erklärung
sagen das sind die Kandidaten bzw
diejenigen die dann später auch mit
darüber entscheiden wie die Wahlen
durchgeführt werden in den einzelnen
Staaten also kein unwichtiges Amt und
vielleicht auch da noch mal die Frage
die ich damit
verbinde auch MRT wir sind hat es
angesprochen es sind einige dabei die
dieser Geschichte der begleich bzw des
bikstils wenn man es andersrum
betrachtet also dass die Wahl gestohlen
worden dass die man im poliert poliert
worden sei der dieser Geschichte
anhängen also inwieweit muss man das
Berücksichtigen jetzt auch bei diesen
Wahlen ja das sind jetzt wegweisende
Stellungen die quasi oder wegweisende
Ämter die jetzt quasi in Position
gebracht werden wir denken daran dass im
deutschen System die Wahlleiter unserer
Bundesländer alles Beamte sind also
neutrale und zur Verfassung
verpflichtete quasi Angehörige des
Staatsapparates das ist in den USA
anders die state secretaries werden
parteipolitisch gewählt und die ganze
Strategie vom ehemaligen
präsidentschaftsberater Steve Bannon war
dass die republikanische Partei sich in
diesen kleinen Schaltstellen so neu
aufstellt vom pressing Captain also von
den kontrollierenden der einzelnen
Wahllokale hoch zu den State secretaries
dass da nur im besten Fall magerer
Republikaner an der Schaltstelle sitzen
das dann Gespräche wie wir sie auch noch
hier in Deutschland erinnern die die das
aufgezeichnete Gespräch zwischen Donald
Trump und Brad prefensberger dem state
secretary von Georgia der gesagt hat Mr
President ich bin zwar Republikaner aber
ich sehe mich in meinem Amt der
Verfassung verpflichtet und ich kann
Ihnen Ihre Wahlstimmen die sie haben
wollen nicht finden das wäre
Manipulation am Wahlsystem
das umgekehrt solche state secretaries
dann wenn sie massiv der magerbewegung
anhängen und jetzt in dieser Wahl in
diesen mit terms quasi an die Positionen
der Macht kommen für 2024 ja wegweisende
Entscheidungen treffen könnten die dann
wirklich den Raubbau an der
amerikanischen Demokratie repräsentieren
da gibt es je nach bundesstaatliche
Verfassung unterschiedliche
Möglichkeiten das State secretaries auch
ganz andere Wahlmänner kollektive wir
erinnern uns daran dass der Präsident in
den Vereinigten Staaten etwas
umständlich gewählt wird nämlich über
die Wahlmänner dass sie dann ganz andere
Wahlmänner kollektive nach Washington
schicken könnten das war ja der
Bestandteil des Aufstandes des 6 Januars
also die Stage secretaries spielen eine
ganz ganz wichtige Schlüsselrolle und da
ging es den Republikanern der
republikanischen magermaschine darum
jetzt diese Menschen schon in Stellung
zu bringen und wir werden erst in den
nächsten Tagen wissen wie weit sich
diese ja diese Bewegung über das ganze
Land erstreckt das heißt wie gefährlich
ist gegebenenfalls wirklich für das
System der demokratischen Wahl in den
USA 2024 bei der großen
Präsidentschaftswahl sein könnte
magermaschine also nicht mager im Sinne
von dünn sondern mit a am Ende also make
America great again die Trump ultra
Bewegung kann man so sagen also die ja
starken Nationalisten und eben Donald
Trump
untertönig ergeben könnte man sagen wenn
wir jetzt schon mal auf die
Präsidentenwahl in zwei Jahren blicken
und der Name Trump ist ja nun schon
gefallen und wir wissen nicht genau er
hat gesagt er wird nächstes nächste
Woche eine Ankündigung machen
el-mathewesen hat gerade schon
spekuliert eventuell angesichts der
aktuellen Zahlen würde eher seine
kandidur Kandidatur vielleicht doch
nicht verkünden bisher ihre Einschätzung
wird es auf jeden Fall auf ihn
hinauslaufen bei den Republikanern
erstmal ja also die Frage ob die
Kandidatur dann schlussendlich auf
Donald Trump hinausläuft das ist eine
ganz andere und wir sehen das zum
Beispiel unabhängige Wähler sich
offensichtlich weil die mittlerweile
ausgeblieben ist sich ein Donald Trump
nicht unbedingt als
Präsidentschaftskandidat wünschen die
haben dann vielleicht das Kreuzchen bei
den Republikanern auf Bundesstaatenebene
gemacht aber dann eben quasi ja
vielleicht mit zugehaltener Nase dann
doch die Demokraten auf Senats oder auf
kongressebene gewählt und das ist ja
schon ein ganz wichtiges Signal an
Donald Trump oder müsste ein wichtiges
Signal sein aber wir dürfen nicht
vergessen dass wir ein Donald Trump
nicht nur einen persönlichen Narzissten
haben der sehr sehr viel auf sich und
seine eigene Macht hält der sich nicht
ablenken wird von der Tatsache dass
vielleicht nur die Hälfte seiner
unterstützen senatskandidaten durchkommt
aber dass wir auch ein Ex-Präsidenten
haben dem ja wie eine schwere Schlinge
um den Hals verschiedene
Gerichtsprozesse ins Haus stehen die
wirklich nicht nur sehr teuer sein
könnten sondern ihm gegebenenfalls auch
wirklich juristisch bedrängen könnten
und auch wenn es dann quasi keine weiße
Weste ist dass man sich als Kandidat
aufstellt da schwingen ja immer noch
politische ja schwingen immer noch
politische Geflogenheiten mit im
amerikanischen System das heißt wenn auf
föderaler Ebene vom Justizministerium
die Vergehen des Donald Trump weiterhin
geahndet werden dass ihm ein Prozess
gemacht wird während er quasi kandidiert
das kann natürlich ein Don könnte ein
Donald Trump wieder so umdrehen und zu
sagen seht ihr das ganze System ist
korrupt sie wollen mir an den Kragen
also die Perpetuierung die Weiterführung
der großen Lüge das heißt es ist für
Donald Trump im Grunde genommen eine
Versicherungspolice wenn er am 15
November sagt er kandidiere dass ihm
zumindest die Justiz auf Zeit jedenfalls
noch vom Kragen bleibt aber es wird in
jedem Fall eine Vorwahl geben wie es in
jedem Fall in die auch bei jeder Partei
der Fall ist und da bringt sich
natürlich rondes Sentis der nun mit
einer landslide also mit einem großen
Wahlerfolg in Florida neu gewählten oder
wiedergewählten
Position und wie ist die Situation bei
den Demokraten auch Joe wird nicht
jünger um es mal vorsichtig zu
formulieren ja nicht nur wird er nicht
jünger sondern er verliert auch
bei seinen Spruch
das Hass am Umfragen in new
York der schon im Sommer gezeigt dass
ich eigentlich eine größere Mehrheit der
Demokraten jetzt wünschen würde mit
einem anderen Kandidaten ins nächste
Rennen zu gehen 2024 und es ist einem
Präsidenten Joe Biden auch deutlich
bewusst auch da bringen sich schon neue
Kandidaten in Stellung ganz vorneweg der
Gouverneur von Kalifornien Gavin newsim
der etwas Ungewöhnliches gemacht hat in
diesem Wahlkampf nämlich schon mal
Anzeigen geschaltet in Texas in Florida
um zum Teil dort Kandidaten zu
unterstützen aber auch noch mal quasi um
seine politischen Positionen in Staaten
deutlich zu machen die mitunter gerade
demografisch in Bewegung sind und sich
vielleicht 2024 auch anders bewegen
könnten als sie es am heutigen Wahlabend
getan haben also das ist etwas Neues das
Gouverneure sich zur Wahl stellen um
einen präsidentialamt zu begleiten das
ist nicht neu aber das zwei Jahre vor
einer Präsidentschaftswahl Gouverneure
schon quasi nationalen Wahlkampf machen
das lässt einen noch aufmerken also
Gavin newsome ist mit Sicherheit vorgem
und ich könnte mir noch einige andere
Kandidaten aus der klassischen
demokratischen Mitte vorstellen darunter
auch eine klobischer also die Demokraten
werden natürlich jetzt sehr genau
überlegen wie und wann vor allen Dingen
würden die Demokraten in einen
Vorwahlkampf starten die einen
Präsidenten nicht schwach aussehen
lassen sondern die trotzdem dann die
Partei von innen quasi wieder nach vorne
bringen können ja auch das ja keine ganz
einfache Balance Situation das so
hinzubekommen letzter Aspekt den ich mit
Ihnen gerne noch besprechen würde welche
Folgen hätte denn ein Verlust der
Mehrheit der Demokraten jetzt für das
Verhältnis zu Europa zu Deutschland was
würde sich für uns ändern
nun in im ersten Moment nicht extrem
viel weil natürlich die macht quasi in
der Außenpolitik vom weißen Haus von der
Exekutivgewalt ausgeht und natürlich
gestützt durch den Senat denn wenn es um
zum Beispiel die wichtigen Rollen von
Botschaftern von entsprechenden
Positionen geht das hat alles sehr Senat
zu entscheiden und wenn da weiterhin die
Demokraten eine Mehrheit behalten auch
was Gerichte angeht auch den Obersten
Gerichtshof dann könnte es da deutlich
einfacher werden aber was passieren wird
es innenpolit der innenpolitische
Diskurs wird sich verändern er wird
deutlich rauer werden und wir haben es
gehört von Kevin McCarthy von extremen
also dem möglichen Sprecher des des
Unterhauses wir haben es gehört von den
extremen make America great again
Vertretern der Trump schon Partei das
zum Beispiel eben gerade die große
Finanzhilfe der Amerikaner und wir
denken noch mal daran dass das drei
verschiedene große Pakete sind die
Militärhilfe die direkte Finanzhilfe
aber eben auch die Entwicklungshilfe
dass diese weil da quasi auf dem
Prüfstein stünden und das wäre dann
natürlich sehr sehr schwierig wenn das
sich daraufhin deuten würde dass wir
2024 einen Präsidenten bekommen der
nicht an die NATO glaubt das heißt es
würde jetzt für Deutschland und das
würde ich quasi jedem Außenpolitiker in
Deutschland empfehlen jetzt noch mal ans
Reisbrett zu gehen und zu schauen reicht
eigentlich das was wir in die
zeitenwände gepackt haben wenn sich
Amerika von den europäischen
Obligationen von dem was sie Europa und
besonders der Ukraine zugesagt haben
langsam abwenden können weil das Klima
zu Hause so eng wird weil die
Wirtschaftszahlen vielleicht weiter
schrumpfen und den Menschen auf der
Tasche liegen also darauf sollte sich
Europa vorbereiten umgekehrt sollte
Europa dem Präsidenten der weiterhin
demokratisch gewählt im Weißen Haus ist
in die Bresche springen es gibt ganz
viel was wir zurzeit mit den Amerikanern
machen angefangen vom Handels- und
Technologiepark den die EU und die US
machen das muss jetzt behände
weitergehen wir müssen das was wir als
Demokratien weiterhin wollen dass es
unseren und Bürgern durch verschiedene
Handelsabkommen und durch ja eine
Investition in unsere Zukunft gemeinsam
sehr viel sehr schnell besser geht und
da sollten sich die Europäer aber auch
gerade die deutschen jetzt nach vorne
lehnen und einem Joe Biden wenn man so
will auch bei der Klimapolitik und bei
diversen anderen Dingen die für uns und
unsere Werte wichtig sind nach vorne
lehnen um dort so schnell wie möglich
weiterhin Wurzeln zu schlagen die dann
ein Republikaner ein Donald Trump 2024
vielleicht nicht mehr so einfach
auseinandernehmen kann die Analyse und
gleichzeitig eigentlich auch die
Empfehlung von Katherine Klüver ashbrook
deutsch-amerikanische Politik
Wissenschaftlerin Autorin Beraterin ganz
herzlichen Dank für dieses Gespräch
heute morgen
und auch an euch natürlich vielen Dank
für euer mitmachen für die Fragen und
Kommentare und ich vielleicht gerade
noch mal der Hinweis dass ich jetzt im
Moment noch nichts geändert hat aber die
Empfehlung klar an euch auch schaut nach
bei ZDF heute.de zum Beispiel was die
aktuellen Zahlen und Entwicklungen bei
diesen mithören Wahlen in den USA angeht
wir versuchen das immer ganz aktuell zu
halten das noch mal für euch vielen Dank
fürs Mitmachen bis demnächst einen
schönen Tag ciao ciao